well here we freaking
do hello well friends when's the last
time we've done one of these
conversations
now as you guys notice i'm i'm just
going to take the time to have a calm
what the [ __ ]
i'm going to be trying to do something
new on this channel now obviously you
guys noticed in the past few years
i have been doing the genius brain
podcast
um i'm not sure if i did i just scratch
up my laptop right now
oh [ __ ] no i'm good i'm good you guys
know i've been doing the genius brain
podcast and there's a whole bunch of
other stuff i've been doing behind the
scenes
and you know i've addressed this before
but i do want to talk about it again and
people have asked
you know why did you why did you go into
doing
the podcast format there's
a lot of reasons why now you guys know
of habit form if you have been watching
me for
many [ __ ] years i got this thing of
when i do something for too long i have
to switch it up
and the reason why is because honestly
this is just the way i am
all right well before we continue this
video any further listen i know
i have a booger in my nose [ __ ] okay
you don't you don't
point out things that i know about me oh
[ __ ] i fell off oh god
i just woke up so i had a booger in my
nose there you go made fun of myself
before you got to make fun of me
in your [ __ ] face yes right i'm a
loser
whoa that doesn't feel good listen this
quarantine [ __ ] sucks but one of the
things that it has allowed for a lot of
us
out here is to sit and reflect and think
about what the [ __ ] we're doing with our
lives one of the things that i've been
such a huge proponent on specifically
when i talk about this on the podcast is
that
i always talk about um
what do i talk about you [ __ ] idiot
it's a very popular phrase it's analysis
leads to paralysis and what that
basically is saying is that
when you overthink things and you're
constantly analyzing what you should do
instead of actually doing it nothing
gets done
i always always preach about this and
the reason why i say this
and i have said this quite frequently is
that when i usually give advice
i'm not just giving it to you i'm
actually giving it to myself
and i have been in that mode for
probably about two years
analysis leads to paralysis and not in
terms of like outside things right i
have
june b matcha uh shrimp daddy uh wing
chicks and a whole bunch of other food
projects i have
i'm going to be out on this netflix
series that's coming out but i'm talking
about my personal projects
and let me tell you kind of what happens
and because of the way that i scrutinize
what i'm doing and i feel like i should
do something bigger
it ends up me not creating anything at
all
so from here on out i'm going to take a
little bit of my own advice
i'm going to stop not creating things
english i am going to stop not creating
things and what i mean by that is that
i'm going to stop scrutinizing
everything that i put out on this
channel
and i'm just going to create content now
if i'm truly doing this just to be
creative and kind of get my creative
juices flowing
um it shouldn't matter whether people
like it or not as long as i enjoy it
just put it out
and then see what happens let it go let
god
jesus take the wheel just don't just
don't take me off a cliff you know i'm
saying
so basically this is it i am going to
start
i don't know what it is i'm not gonna
even label it it's gonna be vlogging i
don't know what it is i'm going
i'm gonna just start putting up videos
on here i don't even know if it's
considered vlogging
what i'm doing i'm just gonna start
putting up [ __ ] and if it doesn't
turn out that well
i'm just gonna share a little piece of
my life with you and give you guys other
content than just the podcast so
uh you guys are in for a ride i don't
know what's going on
but for the next video we'll see what
happens we will see what happens
oh and by the way before we end this let
me let me just show you something real
quick
look at the outside world right now
whoever the [ __ ] had that
baby shower you have ruined the earth
so california is basically on fire right
now because some
[ __ ] dumbasses decided to have
a baby shower
and some pyrotechnics and just lit up
all of california so right now it looks
post-apocalyptic as [ __ ] but anyways if
you're like me
and you're analyzing things too much and
it causes you not to create something
re-evaluate what you're doing right now
you can't get better at something if
you're not practicing and if you're not
putting things into motion it could be a
vlog it could be you talking in the
camera
it could be just about anything but at
the end of the day if you're not
creating
you're not really working on your craft
and right now my craft has dwindled so
bad i was trying to write a sketch
yesterday
my god i was just pacing around in my
room doing absolutely nothing throwing
like kung fu and karate kicks just to
get the juices flowing
cause your mama's a bit cause your mom
cause your mama's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] funny
that's nothing [ __ ] do with the story
[ __ ]
[ __ ] why do you keep saying [ __ ]
these [ __ ] nothing happened
i just ended up sitting on the floor and
crying [ __ ] but if you're out there and
you want to be a content creator
i challenge you to do this with me just
start creating it doesn't have to be
every day
in terms of putting out a product or a
video but let's work on something every
day
let's challenge ourselves let's let's
make ourselves a little uncomfortable
because there's
nothing worse than sitting around
talking about what-ifs
and having to look back at your passes
saying i could have done more so
you guys heard it from me first this is
what we gonna do
let's get it baby love you